when we define greatness we often look
to the past to the people who have been
remembered to the explorers that risk
their lives to discover new worlds and
rightly so but the people who made their
mission possible are often lost in
history
what of the ship right who made the
Santa Maria strong enough to survive the
wild Atlantic who were the engineers
that worked tirelessly to make the
Apollo lunar lander light enough so the
astronauts could come back home
these names may often be lost in history
but we can celebrate their memory by
appreciating their work these people
were real engineers they took ideas and
made them a reality by combining art and
science taking figments of their
imagination wild visions of the future
and making them a reality by realizing
their dreams and stone metal plastic and
code they changed the lives of men and
women across this planet from the
subtlest of inventions to the big
game-changing technologies they elevate
the standard of living reduce the time
of your commute help farmers feed more
people and give doctors the tools they
need to save more lives this is what
real engineering is about real
engineering is creating a better future
you